[Music]
the library you go wild for Easter I
won't have an Easter egg hunt we'll
definitely get the kids a little high on
chocolate and I'm trying to find someone
that will dress up as the Easter Bunny
grab your chocolate shaped rabbits hide
your eggs and let's hop to it we're
running down our favorite stars who love
Easter just as much as we do we go to
church in the morning and then we have a
big brunch afterwards and then we have
an Easter egg hunt like most holidays
the Kardashians do it up real big they
have a massive brunch with tons of
desserts and of course a visit from the
Easter Bunny real bunnies and an egg
hunt but they're hardly the only famous
family that goes all out on your marks
get set go Kate Hudson's brother Oliver
led last year's epic egg hunt even
Kate's ex matt bellamy joined the party
clearly this fam doesn't mess around
here's goldie hawn helping out looking
for the golden eggs okay well let's do
it let's get down here and look on the
ground okay but the cuteness doesn't end
there here's Neil Patrick Harris his
twins Gideon and Harper loving that egg
life mariah carey and nick cannon went
on a hunt with their twins Moroccan and
Monroe and Channing Tatum's wife jenna
dewan snapped this adorable shot of
their daughter everly before we wrap up
moment of appreciation for easter
fashion please paris hilton knows how to
rock a onesie and a classy dress reese
witherspoon ops for a situational
outfits loving those pink birds Ariel
winter did her best sexy easter bunny
look in a plunging white number while
lily aldridge just straight up went for
it ears tail and all I feel very
comfortable and confident as a woman all
right I'm gonna go wipe out my chocolate
stash tweet me let me know which
celebrity you think does Easter best and
I'll catch you later peeps get it
heaps
you